لا هدنى صمدت ولا حسم يلوح بالافق نوبات
قتال شرعت لها ارض السودان الخصبه
للنزاعات مع غياب استعداد للتسويه شبكه من
المصالح والتقاطعات الاقليميه والدوليه
القت بظلالها على مشهد السودان السياسي
باستمرار في ظل موقعه الافريقي المتميز
ومساعي طي الازمه السياسيه افرز التقسيمات
في تعامل بعض الدول مع الازمه
علاقات الخرطوم المتميزه بالروس ليست
جديده تعد موسكو حليفا دبلوماسيا وعسكريا
لها تمكنت من خلالها توسيع حلقات تعاونها
الامني مع السودان خاصه مع امتلاك الاخير
موقعا مهما على البحر الاحمر المصالح وصلت
الى كنز السودان المدفون الذهب اتهم الغرب
مجموعه فاجن الروسيه بالتورط في انشطه غير
قانونيه لتعدين الذهب في السودان اما
بالنسبه للجناح الغربي وواشنطن فسعادتهم
التخلص من البشير التي تتهمه المحكمه
الدوليه بارتكاب جرائم حرب اثناء الصراع
في دارفور لم تملا تصدعات هذا البلد الهش
كما اتهمت واشنطن بالتلكؤ في دعم الانتقال
نحو اجزاء انتخابات اما بالنسبه للصين يعد
السودان حلقه وسط مهمه بين المحيطين
العربي والافريقي لكنها تبنت نهجا اكثر
حذرا تجاه الصراع في السودان اتسعى الى
الحفاظ على التوازن بين مصالح الاقتصاديه
والالتزام بعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
للدول الاخرى
الصراع بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع اجتذب مشاركه كبيره من اللاعبين
الاقليميين والدوليين ولكل منهم دوافعه
ومصالحه الخاصه
اياد حمود العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات